[Music]  call and text everyday moments college  it's not a survival course it'll be fine  [Music]  okay are you a virgin I'll do dare I  dare you to make out with heart I'm done  playing this game I like this girl  deep question who is hard and scoff I  think that it's better if we keep our  distance welcome to my favorite place  thought that you just wanted to friends  I think we can never be just friends cuz  I just can't stop thinking about you  you are stunning  nothing could ever change the way that I  feel about you just be careful what  happened it has to do with hard  something's going on but it's not what  you think it's making a big mistake  I'm just gonna break your arm  what are you dreaming about  [Music]